У 2019 році Джон Гуденаф, Стенлі Віттінгем та Акіра Йошино здобули
Нобелівську премію з хімії.
Відкриття наших лауреатів кардинально змінили наше суспільство.
Вони винайшли та розробили технологію, якою більшість із нас користується щодня.
Часто, не замислюючись про це. Вона у наших бездротових навушниках,
смартфонах, ноутбуках, пилососах та електросамокатах. Йдеться про це.
Літій-іонний акумулятор.
Ми можемо їздити з ним - без спалювання викопного палива.
Але що потрібно для виготовлення всіх цих батарей?
Що ми робимо з ними, коли вони вже відпрацювали своє?
І яке відношення все це має до LEGO? Давайте з’ясуємо.
Автомобіль приніс комфорт та незалежність мільярдам людей.
Але величезна кількість бензину та дизельного палива,
що ми спалюємо під час їзди, негативно впливає на клімат.
У нас енергетична криза.
Завдяки літій-іонним акумуляторам ми вже на початку нової ери мобільності.
Висока щільність енергії робить їх ідеальними для використання в електрокарах.
Вони вміщують багато енергії, не потребуючи багато місця.
Літій-іонна батарея багато де уможливила декарбонізацію.
Це Ганс Ерік Мелін.
Він заснував консалтингову компанію, яка спеціалізується на літій-іонних акумуляторах.
У сфері мобільності літій-іонний акумулятор - це справді ключова технологія.
У цьому секторі є величезний потенціал.
Виробництво настільки велике, що це значно знижує витрати на батареї.
За різними оцінками, кількість електромобілів у світі значно зросте до кінця десятиліття.
Приблизно з 8 до 116 мільйонів.
Звичайно, це означає, що попит на літій-іонні акумулятори також зросте,
що принесе нові проблеми.
Звичайно, це має свою ціну. Для виробництва батарей нам потрібна сировина.
І видобуток сировини завжди впливає на довкілля.
Логічно, що літій - доволі важливий для виготовлення літій-іонної батареї.
Близько 50 відсотків світових запасів лужного металу міститься тут -
у так званому літієвому трикутнику між Аргентиною, Болівією та Чилі.
Для видобутку корисних речовин солона вода перекачується з підземних озер
у басейни, де вона випаровується. Цей процес може пошкодити
навколишній ґрунт, виснажити запаси води та забруднити повітря.
Крім того, запаси літію небезмежні. За даними одного з досліджень,
якщо попит продовжить зростати такими темпами, то приблизно в середині століття
можуть початися перебої.
У літій-іонних батареях є ще кобальт, великі поклади якого є у Демократичній Республіці Конго.
Його видобуток часто пов'язаний з нелюдськими умовами праці та дитячою працею.
А ще потрібна енергія для виробництва батарей. Особливо для виробництва
внутрішніх елементів.
А це означає викиди CO2. Скільки саме - залежить від структури
енергосистеми країни-виробника. Але згідно з останніми даними,
виробництво акумулятора для отакого маленького автомобіля
може спричинити чотири тонни СО2. Для порівняння: це приблизно стільки,
скільки викидає новий дизельний автомобіль у ЄС, проїжджаючи 33 тисячі кілометрів.
Гарна новина в тому, що викиди зменшуються, оскільки виробництво акумуляторів
стає більш ефективним, і багато країн збільшують частку відновлюваних джерел енергії.
Погана ж новина полягає в тому, що батареї з часом втрачають
здатність заряджатися. Тож дедалі більше електромобілів також означає
дедалі більше відпрацьованих акумуляторів.
Ми повинні збирати їх, сортувати і повторно використовувати для різних цілей.
Ада Конг - авторка доповіді саме про це для відділу "Грінпіс" у Східній Азії.
Акумулятори для електромобілів мають велику потужність.
Якщо приблизно через 5-8 років вони вже не придатні для використання в авто,
їх все одно можна використовувати деінде.
Ми можемо дати відпрацьованим акумуляторам друге життя. Наприклад,
вони можуть зберігати енергію вітру та сонця. Або забезпечити енергією
ваш наступний виїзд на кемпінг. І їм все ще вистачає потужності
для керування автонавантажувачем. Або човном. Викинуті електробатареї
нині вже для всього цього використовуються.
Ми повинні продовжити термін експлуатації цих матеріалів, використовуючи їх і надалі.
І коли вони вже дійсно вичерпаються, ми можемо переробляти їх
і створювати з них нові вироби.
Скористаймося конструктором LEGO, щоб унаочнити, як можна переробляти літій-іонні батареї.
Часто це відбувається шляхом їхнього розплавлення. Однак це споживає багато енергії,
виділяє токсичні гази, і ви втрачаєте частину сировини.
Тому компанії працюють над новими процесами переробки.
Це цінна сировина, яку ми з великими зусиллями добули з-під землі.
Ми повинні використовувати її якомога сумлінніше і так довго, як тільки можна.
Кунал Фалфер - комерційний директор канадської переробної компанії Li-Cycle,
що спеціалізується на літій-іонних батареях.
Ми розробили процес, який виокремлює особливо велику кількість сировини.
Наш перший крок - це механічний процес. Батареї тут подрібнюються,
а матеріали грубо сортуються.
Дуже спрощуючи, ось як це працює. Акумулятори подрібнюють у хімічному розчині.
Це важливо, оскільки це запобігає загорянню акумуляторів і, в гіршому випадку, вибуху.
Потім такі речовини, як пластик, мідь та алюміній, відокремлюються
від так званої "чорної маси". Там міститься цінна сировина - кобальт, нікель та літій.
Другий крок - це гідрометалургія, вологий хімічний процес. Тут "чорна маса"
розділяється на окрему сировину, яку можна повернути на виробництво акумуляторів.
Це означає, що до "чорної маси" додаються хімічні речовини,
кожна з яких виокремлює різні елементи. Ці хімічні речовини або
потрапляють у кінцевий продукт, або переробляються таким чином,
що не створюються стічні води. Врешті-решт "чорну масу" розділяють
на окремі компоненти, передусім літій, кобальт і нікель.
Наша кінцева мета - витягнути речовини зі старих батарей, а потім помістити їх у нові.
Це ще не відбувається у великих масштабах. Але ми вже спостерігаємо
перші спроби у всьому світі. І ми хочемо сприяти такому розвитку.
Важко точно визначити, скільки літій-іонних батарей уже переробляється
- особливо тому, що їх часто експортують. Але переробки стає дедалі більше і більше,
особливо в Азії, де, до речі, більшість з них і виготовляється.
І що більше старих акумуляторів, то більше фінансово привабливим це буде.
В ідеальному світі ми не добували б жодної нової сировини. І ми б продовжували
використовувати необмежений час всю сировину, яку ми вже видобули.
Літій-іонна батарея вже є одним з найбільш циклічних продуктів.
Її вже використовують повторно і, зрештою, навіть переробляють.
Ми можемо оптимізувати це ще більше.
І чим більше акумуляторів на ринку, тим очевидніше це буде.